Der mit europäischem Haftbefehl gesuchte
ehemalige katalanische Regierungschef Carles
Puigdemont ist in Deutschland festgenommen
worden.
Sowohl sein Anwalt als auch das Landespolizeiamt
Schleswig-Holstein erklärten, der Katalane
sei an der deutsch-dänischen Grenze festgesetzt
worden.
Nach Angaben des Anwalts war Puigdemont auf
der Rückreise von Finnland nach Belgien.
Der Oberste Gerichtshof Spaniens hatte am
Freitag Strafverfahren gegen Puigdemont und
weitere Regionalpolitiker eröffnet.
Ihnen drohen bis zu 25 Jahre Haft.
Puigdemont hatte im Oktober die Unabhängigkeit
Kataloniens von Spanien ausgerufen und damit
gegen die Verfassung verstoßen.
Darauf leitete die Justiz Ermittlungen wegen
Rebellion gegen Puigdemont und andere führende
Separatisten ein.
Puigdemont floh nach Belgien ins Exil.